on today's show we talked to a young
woman whose boyfriend left
when he found out she was pregnant and
she wants to know what to do
we talked to a young woman who wants to
know how do i end friendships that
aren't romantic
and i talked to a young man who was
recently divorced and his family is
pressuring him to get married
again and by the way we talk about
whether we can root for the astros
who are a bunch of cheaters stay tuned
hey what's up what's up this is john
with the dr john deloney show
hope you're doing well hope things are
going well in your life and if they're
not i hope you're on track to get things
turned around
hope you got folks who are walking along
with you and if you don't i'm glad
you're with us and if you do i'm glad
you're with us
we are gonna talk about everything on
the show today that's not really true i
just say that all the time and now it's
just become routine and it just comes
out of my mouth and then right when i
say it i'm like no we're not we talk
about like three or four things and
that's it and then we move on but
uh i like to speak almost entirely in
hyperbole right
so i hope you're doing well if you don't
know what hyperbole means look it up
and let's just start here if you want to
be on the show
give me a shout at um with zac you
pointing
you look beautiful um one eight four
four six nine three thirty two ninety
one
that's one eight four four six nine
three three two nine one
zach is the video guy back there and he
makes it all happen
it's just a good spot here zach um i
can't hear him
in the studio i can only hear uh
james and kelly's lovely lovely voices
telling me how much
i'm tanking the show on a regular basis
and what i should be doing
otherwise professionally other than the
show and i can only hear from zach i can
only see zach out of the corner of my
eye
and it's a thumbs up or a thumbs down
that's how he speaks to me exclusively
thumbs up
thumbs down um sometimes shows get lots
of thumbs down
and it hurts my self-esteem and my
feelings but zack
hey listen um baseball season has
started
and you're a huge braves fan which is
embarrassing for you and your family but
it is what it is
i've got a problem and i need you just
to solve it with a thumbs up or thumbs
down
to the listeners to the show i am a
die-hard to the death since i was
born a houston astro fan i was born in
houston
uh raised in houston we used to go my
buddies and i used to go to the
to the astros games when they were four
dollars in the astrodome it's four bucks
general admission in the outfield
and we would just terrorize um you know
outfielders back then
and uh just it's just a part of my soul
and so then when they won the world
series a few years ago
i was i wept i woke my son up i cried it
was this moment
and now i find out there are a bunch of
cheaters they cheated the whole thing
so we took a mandatory year off but it
wasn't even a real year because
it was shortened here's the thing zach
as a baseball fan
i'm looking for you for some moral
guidance here can we be fans again
or do we just have are the astros done
are they dead to us
oh my gosh see here's the thing as a
braves fan they're dead tim what do you
think
oracle james i could not have less of an
opinion on that
you know i just want to play my guitars
and make make beats with my
with pro tools ah james hates all
american pastimes
and that's why he plays fender guitar
i've been playing catch with my son in
the yard a lot
i don't care about the astros i've been
playing catch with my son
look at me trying to be an all-american
guy all american dad
part of me wants to bring the astros
back zach
and part of me is just still stuck if
you have an opinion
i guess email kelly and she'll delete it
faster than you can actually send it in
but zach gives me the thumbs down like
any good braves fan would because here's
the thing
the braves aren't that good and the
astros routinely beat them and embarrass
them and their families
and so of course zach's gonna be like no
down with the astros
i don't know what to do man it's a moral
dilemma for me i do remember man
i had to sit down and talk to my son
about it and say hey this team that we
rooted
for and cheered for they cheated and
we like it and my son was so like
devastated astros you ruined my
relationship with my son
you didn't actually gave me a good
teaching moment and you also
gave me like hours and hours of my month
back because i quit checking on scores
and stuff and started quote-unquote
playing with my family
and then my relationships got better in
my house that was all good
i don't know i'm just torn on what to do
i'm gonna i think i'm gonna
i don't know we'll just have to i'm
gonna call into the show
and talk to myself about it but no more
talking about the astros they've ruined
enough of my life let's go to amanda in
fargo north dakota
amanda how in the world are you oh i'm
doing all right dr john thanks for
talking with me
thank you so much for calling i hope
you're doing well how can i help what's
going on
well i'm pregnant excellent
congratulations i think thank you um
my boyfriend dumped me because i
wouldn't get an abortion
oh golly i'm so sorry um
how far along are you um
18 and a half weeks 18 and a half weeks
okay so this thing's
this thing's happening yep yeah okay
um so tell me what's going on your heart
and mind what are we doing here
well i think he might change his mind
and come around
if nothing else at least to be a part of
the child's life essentially
so i'm just wondering if i how do i
prepare for that
or do i just go on as if i'm on my own
what makes you think he's going to come
around after
he bailed on you he he has a big heart
he really does um he hasn't he didn't
show it
no he didn't um are you a lot of people
remember disappointed in that well they
should be
um because he failed you is he
are are you super optimistic woman
yes i am okay so are you
seeing this your life is is changed
dramatically you're gonna have a baby
this is exciting and scary
and how old are you i'm almost 35.
okay so you are all in on this thing um
you've lived life you know what's up
live life they made it sound like i just
called you ancient i'm not doing that
but you're not 17. my doctor did too no
i'm not
oh dude if you're 35 and you tell your
doctor you're pregnant they're basically
like
prepare you for end times and i hate it
it's so awful
i ugh my wife had to go through that
where they're like well you know that
um you're gonna come in here on a walker
and that
it's awful so good for you so
um but you're not 17 right so
you've you have seen life you understand
life are you
making a fantasy out of this
relationship with this guy because
that's how you're getting through every
day
no i mean i i have two other kids
okay um i've been divorced for
11 years and so i've been a single mom
for
11 years they're going to be 12 and 13
this summer
okay so i mean it's that's not new to me
yeah but yeah but the reality of it
happening again is
super new to you yeah and
my guess is you are equally excited and
equally
what is happening to me
yeah it's i wasn't expecting to be alone
but i mean my thing with him is
like he's super affectionate to his dog
and super affectionate to his lizard and
like
hey listen i'm laughing with you not at
you okay
no um he takes takes the lizard out of
the cage and gives her a bath and calls
her honey
and you know amanda amanda lizard
it's a lizard literally the insides of
my body
are twisting around as you're talking
but he's got a lot of compassion
you know what he doesn't he he had here
he has compassionate about
animals that he controls yeah he does
not have compassion
the reckless wild um
unabashed love that you have for
somebody that you're going to create
life with
he does not have that reckless i'll do
anything i'll burn the city down for for
my child love that a parent has
he has a lizard that he lets walk around
his apartment
right that is not the same thing this
dude is super
super super lame and i
hate hate that he's responded to you
this way and i hate that he's responded
to
his future baby this way um can you come
around
yes of course um many many and many of
people
sat down with my wife before she married
me and had these dramatic cups of coffee
telling
her how lame i was right yeah so
he can come around he is not there and
um
i hate this hate this for you what what
is it about him that is making you
dig so deep to find some redeeming
quality that you are now
trying to compare a child with a lizard
i think that's just the type of person i
am
the type of per that you try you will
mine the depths of hell to try to find
something good about somebody or
that you are that you live in an alt
universe so that your today will be okay
or both um it's i i look for the best in
people
okay you are looking really really hard
okay yeah and i mean like three and a
half years it wasn't
it wasn't uh a two month sling or
something like that you know i've
i've seen what he's capable of and
knowing his potential and
but that also makes the devastation that
much deeper and greater when he bails on
you when you need him the most
yeah right and
it it can pull the rug out from under
you when you think i know somebody and
we're down the road on this thing i'm
not gonna be alone
and i trust him with my kids and i don't
trust anybody with my kids
and i trusted this guy and then all of a
sudden things got
really real and he's out right
he may turn around you're right i hope
hope hope for a thousand different
reasons i hope he does
um but i don't want you
continually kicking this fantasy down
the road and just prolonging the
inevitable that
you may be raising a third kid as a
single mom
yeah and so here's a just a phrase i
live my life by
it's just one of those cornerstone
sayings
um things usually turn out okay and
sometimes they don't
right and so i live my life pretty
optimistically
and i don't owe anybody any money just
in case right
i live a really non-violent life i don't
get angry at people very often at all
and i trained in mixed martial arts for
years and years
and i know how to handle a gun right so
i
never want to use these things but if
right
and so what i that same principle will
apply to you here
meaning you've got to wrap your head
around a reality
where you are going to be taking care of
a third kid by yourself
and you're going to have that decade gap
that is going to be both exciting
and terrifying right because now you're
both dropping third graders off and
changing diapers
and you are both um going to a fourth
grade graduation and a soccer game and
trying to squeeze nap time in
right you're all that is very very real
and you're going to have to figure out
rent and a network of support
and what kind of job you can get that's
going to give you the time off but also
support
you're going to do that and
you've got to prepare to share this
child with his father for the rest of
his life
because it's about the kid not about you
right
right and you regardless of how much
this guy
sucks as a partner as a guy who should
be sitting by your side right now
this is still going to be that kid's dad
right
and so how do you prepare a world where
you have to operate
all the machinery and i also have to
honor this idiot because this idiot is
the father of my kid
and that's a hard both end right um
my boys dad hasn't seen them in almost
eight years
so it's like i said that's kind of so
guys who sucks familiar
you live in that world right um yeah
i hate this for you i really do
how are your other two boys doing great
fantastic um one of them just graduated
out of the reading 180 class and got to
start a tech class he's super excited
for the 3d printer
yeah awesome the other one it says last
couple months of
fifth grade so they'll both be in middle
school next year
um they're going to go spend the summer
with grandma
about 200 miles away so i can focus on
work and getting some money saved up and
so grandma's not lonely during the
summer
that would be a lot of fun they have an
adventure so are you going to be lonely
there
growing up growing a kid number three or
is this going to be a time for you just
to
make snow angels in the carpet with with
no middle schoolers running around
well we'll see um i'm scheduled 10 hour
days at my job
they've been really understanding with
all my appointments and everything
recently
i have a dog i have two horses um
i can reconnect with some of my friends
hey this is great news along with your
horses your boyfriend's got a lizard
right oh my gosh all right so here's the
thing
if dad comes back into the picture right
this is gonna be about you and him
and your relationship because he loves
you
not just to duct tape and stitch
together some sort of pseudo
relationship
so that you all can all pretend that
it's going to be great because there's a
baby on the way
right because you've lived that life
right
you've tried to make the stuff work with
the other with the dad of the other two
boys and it doesn't right
you've been down this road yeah okay
i want to make sure you don't compromise
your soul for
for an idiot with a with a reptile well
that's
that's how the abortion didn't happen i
wasn't going to compromise
who i was and my beliefs in that
standing
i mean i i take responsibility for the
mistake i made with not telling him it
was a possibility at the time
and so that that other precautions
weren't
taken but other than that he's a grown
up too
hey listen he's a grown-up too amanda
okay
everybody's in this deal together right
um
what did the breakup look like i'm just
trying to wrap my head around what's a
what's a conversation
when's the last time you all talked um
well i had a piece of mail at his place
yesterday
okay um so
i found out in january and
uh told him um
we looked at it did i was open to
looking at the options
there was three times that i told him
that this was what i had decided
twice i said okay i'll i'll think some
more
um you were really thinking were you
trying to just
get him to go down the road a little bit
with you
it was a little bit of both i mean it is
a lot of but like i said
it it kept coming back to it's a life
and i'm being asked to
kill something for a relationship and
um because he did say if if i was to get
the abortion that he would put a
more solid effort into repairing our
relationship because it had been a
little bit rough for
the last year or so amanda this guy
sucks
like i don't i'm not in the business of
talking bad about other people's
partners but this guy's no good yeah
anybody who's gonna put an ultimatum on
your values
and then they're gonna work harder your
relationship
is not worth the the air you're
breathing they're not
that's not how relationships work you
don't have these conditional
if you do this uh i'll start trying to
to love you a little bit better that's
not how that works yeah
and i told him i said you know the baby
is a guaranteed thing
a relationship with you even without the
baby is
not necessarily a guaranteed thing well
yeah take some take the emotional charge
of the baby off the table
um if he comes in and says hey listen
if you start mowing the yard i'm i'm
gonna really
i'll start making an effort then he
sucks if he says that
right the effort is because you are you
right because your relationship's worth
salvaging
every relationship goes through really
messy muddy
ugly like no grass left in the yard
seasons
every relationship the best marriages on
earth there's moments when people
are hanging on by the fingernails that's
the nature of it right
and it always comes back to they're
worth it
this is worth it right and then you
start scratching and clawing and making
your way back
right right and so
it's not you know what if you perform
and achieve
then i'm back in that's not how that
works man
because then the whole base of the
relationship is
on what you do for me
and man there's there is no found
relational foundation for that
it's what i do for you and
then what you do for me and then now
we're building something
right so yeah amanda
i i'm telling you even if he says i'm
coming back i would think long and hard
about bringing him back just to
the the character of the person you've
told me who he is
right yeah yeah and do you want this guy
to do you want to build right the
foundation of your house with this dude
moving forward
man um i don't know i know there's two
sides to every story i know there's a
whole bunch here
um bottom line is you have to prepare
your heart and mind and that's a
dramatic way of saying you got to
prepare your finances
your living situation your kids your
in-laws
your job where you live do you have
enough support
not just emotional support and somebody
bringing you casserole support but do
you have babysitting support and do you
have
um financial support i mean do you have
people in your life that are going to
hold your arms up in the desert when
this thing gets hard because you
you think you remember what it's like
having a newborn a promise you don't
i forgot i for super forgot and i had
five years between them
not a thousand like you do um
and then the second thing is if this guy
looks in the mirror one day and says i
can't be this guy anymore and i
you know me i want to be about
redemption all day long
and he knocks on your door and says i
screwed up bad and i'm all in
i'm all in on you i'm all in on this
baby i'm all in
on your other two boys then you say cool
before i do anything say anything we're
going to see a marriage therapist now
we're going to go see a relationship
counselor today or tomorrow morning
and you're taking off work and we're
going and we're going to build this
thing from the floor up we're not going
to recreate what was because what was
was
awful where you were forced
into searching so
hard for a shred of humanity in this
dude that you were trying to compare
a new baby to a lizard he loves us he
lets his lizard out of the cage
oh my gosh and he hugs his dog totally
different and you know that amanda you
know
and i applaud your effort into trying to
find humanity here
i applaud it but here's what happens and
i want everyone listening to hear this
sometimes when we spend
this much energy amanda that you're
spending
trying to find humanity in others we
give up our own
in search of theirs we give up who we
are we give up what we actually
know to be right we give up what the
values that we have we give up
our futures and hopes and dreams we give
up our voice
because he's got a lizard like i'm
trying to find something right we do
that with politicians we do that with
our religious institutions we do that
with school
we try so hard to find some redeeming
value we end up way down a road we
never thought we'd be down ever thought
we'd be down
because we're trying to find some
redeeming glimmer of hope and what i
want everyone to do is to stop and look
in the mirror and say who
am i what are my values what is right
and if you don't know find somebody that
you trust and say where are we man
and then you build it from there you
build it from there out right
not the other way around i love love
love your heart amanda
you're in for a long road you know this
you've got two other kids and you're in
for a
ex extraordinary beautiful
life-altering adventure right and this
new baby is going to be loved he's going
to have two knuckleheaded brothers that
are going to love him like crazy
he's going to have a mama that loves him
like crazy
and you know what he's gonna have a
lizard owning dad who's gonna
love him in his weird way too and you're
gonna have to figure out how to make
peace with that because this little
kid's gonna need his dad too
however misguided and goofy and broken
dad is he's gonna need that too
and dad if you're listening to this fix
it it's not too late
it's not too late to turn it around all
right let's go to uh
anna in phoenix arizona anna what's
going on how can i help
hey john how are you today you know what
i was doing great to learn about that
last call but
i'm doing good i'm back to doing good
now that we're talking anna how are you
hey good question
is what is the what is an appropriate
way
to end relationships specifically
friendships
that detract from your personal or
professional
growth so it's a broad topic yeah
it's funny i was just talking to some
buddies the other day like we don't have
like grown-up
like you don't have breakups with your
regular friends right you only have
breakups with romantic friends we don't
have like a
a cultural system for saying like i
don't want to be your friend anymore so
please never
we don't have that right we just quit
returning their calls basically um
exactly and i don't want to do that okay
so you have you have something going on
so tell me what's actually happening in
your world like put a put a context for
this
yep so i've got like lots of beautiful
people in my life and even the ones i'm
trying to end
relationships with they're also great
people
um but they've kind of there's a there's
a couple of them who've
put me on this pedestal almost and have
become very obsessive
and demand a lot of my attention and
time okay
and i've tried setting boundaries
they're not respected
and so i just want to figure out how to
end it give me an example of you set a
boundary
and they didn't respect it what does
that look like oh wait
so i took my medical boards a couple
months ago
i took it i passed yeah dude way to go
all of america just cheered we only have
like 32 listeners but we're all cheering
for you
that's so good awesome and these are
your boards for med school
these are your med school oh
congratulations that's so cool
way to go right and you as you
understand they were incredibly
exhausting like you're in a hole for
months studying
um and afterwards i had told everybody
like hey
i'm gonna lay in my bed for like three
days
after responding to anybody right well
deserved
and like one of the people was
just so happened to be 30 minutes away
from her home in my neighborhood
and just like showed up so things like
that and it's like i made it clear i
need alone time
in my bed yeah so is
is that enough that you want to end
relationships or are you about to move
across
country like when you say i want to end
this thing what does that mean
you want them to never call you again
i guess not but i don't know how to set
the boundaries
like i would be there for anybody if
even if like some stranger broke down on
the side of the road you know
and they're like hey you help and i
would of course um but hey it's
way way easier to help strangers than it
is to help
people that are in relationship with
right
right and they are good people because
if they were a jerk it'd be easy to end
right but it's like if i give them an
inch they keep trying to take a mile and
i'm
it's just exhausting even telling them
no all the time
um so and when they ask a lot it's like
eventually you say yes and then
you just drink they wear you down what
kind of doctor are you going to be
um so i want to go into endocrinology
okay
that's the path and for those who don't
know what that is
give them a 30 second primer on
endocrinology
um so i want to so it's like a little
bit unconventional but i want to help
people so as a personal trainer and
nutritionist prior so i want to help
people with lifestyle changes to
balance hormones but overall
give hormones as needed to get people
into balance and then change behaviors
excellent so there's two things at play
here
number one i think there's a part of you
that loves loves
loves being the go-to person in your
community
and i know that because i'm the same way
and it's exhausting too is that fair
yes and so it is super cool to have
people reach out ask questions my guess
is you've always been the smart one in
your crew you've always been the fun one
that will do crazy things you've been in
med school you've been everybody's
token med school friend right and
that also comes with a cost because they
call you at all hours of the night hey
you look at this weird mole what do you
think about this
is coveted real like you do that all the
time right
exactly um and so
it's exhausting also and it's especially
exhausting when people think they have a
friend who's a doctor
or a mental health person or a finance
person
um their emergencies always has to be
your emergency right
and so they call all the time what is it
about you
that won't just turn your phone off like
you make this announcement
i want a three-day sabbatical from earth
why didn't you just turn your phone off
and not answer the door
yeah that's a good question it's because
i tell people like
it's because i know it's not gonna it's
because you kind of liked it
and yeah you wanna be connected but you
want to be connected on your terms and
those aren't real boundaries
those are pretend boundaries right or i
call them indignant boundaries
um it's where i will
go by i don't i'll come up with some
terrible analogy here
they're just indignant boundaries right
there they're screen doors they're not
walls
and then i want to be able to see out
there and make sure everybody's doing
good make sure i'm still important
but when you call i'm like what are you
doing why are you right
and so i would say when you put up a
boundary
you have ownership there it's your
responsibility to draw that line
a and then hold that line because people
are going to test and see if that
boundary
it holds firm or not and if you're
um this is cool that you're learning
this on the front end of what's about to
be a long journey
to become a licensed medical doctor
because it's going to just get crazier
for you
you're going to be this way for everyone
in your community you're going to have
friends of friends who
call you right this is just going to be
your life
and so when you set a boundary
then you are then responsible for making
sure that wall's firm
right it really bugged my
buddies when i would start turning my
phone off on the weekends
it bugged me more and then
quickly everybody kind of just learned
right and now
i i'm not so militant about it and i'm
kind of sad that my friends don't call
me on the weekends
but i set that boundary that's that's me
right i set it up right
so that's number one it's super annoying
that you put that out into the universe
i don't want anyone to check on me
but my guess is you've set up boundaries
like that before and then people show up
and you're like oh come on in
and you have coffee and ice cream
together and you all hang out and have
some laughs
they leave and then you get indignant
about it so i would say
you put it out they violated your
boundary but you opened the door they
showed back up so if you want to have
those boundaries draw them
here's the second thing
you are entering into a profession where
the crux of your success in this
profession is not going to be academic
there's a lot of smart people it's not
going to be the information you quote
unquote have in your head
it's going to be how you communicate
hard truths to people in a vulnerable
and exposed way
and let them hear and listen to you
not be devastated by you and then know
you love them but then they've got to go
make behavioral life changes right right
this will be most you you'll be most
successful in this
if you can have some congruence which is
the nerd rogerian word for
i'm the same person at home as i am at
work as i am at
the store as i mature the more you can
be the same person
the better right and you know where i'm
going here
the more you can sit down with one of
your friends who you love and say hey
look
i'm taking a three-day sabbatical from
life for sure don't call me i'm gonna
turn my phone off i love you
or if they show up and bang and ring the
doorbell ring the doorbell ring the
doorbell
you meet him at the door and you say hey
i
seriously i love you but this is some
sacred time for me
and i can't hang out and i know it's
gonna be super frustrating but i don't
want to so i'll give you a call in two
days after my sabbatical with life is
over
and you shut the door in a gentle
compassionate loving way
and then if they've sit there and honk
their horn and they
air horn out your window that's when you
call the police on him and say i have a
crazy person in my front yard right
um but all that to say is learning how
to have these compassionate
but direct loving but hard conversations
which don't have to be a production they
don't have to be a show
they're just simply here's my boundary
here's my truth and you're not
you're not i don't like that phrase my
truth because there's
we weaponize that but here's my boundary
and you're not
um i've asked you two or three times to
not text me after 10 o'clock
and i turn my phone off and you keep
texting you keep calling you keep
knocking on my door
um why do you keep violating my
boundaries right that's that's this
that's going to be the
an easier version of five years from now
when you sit down and say
hey you have thyroid cancer and we're
going to take this out and you're going
to have to have some exogenous
hormones for a season and you're gonna
have to really change your diet or
you're gonna die
right that's that's just a precursor to
that conversation
so let's practice really quick so
give me a new boundary in your life okay
i am i'm
a new boundary in my life yeah i will
not answer the phone i'm gonna say
after 7pm because i go to bed early
dude you just made mine you just made my
heart feel good
doctors that get a full night of sleep
change lives everybody
so um okay cool so i'm just gonna knock
on your door
hey uh anna what's up let's go party
there's some super cute fill in the
blank that's fill in the blank
and the show starts at nine you're
coming
and then i open do i not open the door i
don't know
you you're the grown up here you're the
one who's about to be a doctor
you tell me yeah if i hear them talking
about
so i open the door uh hey sorry
i told you i'm turning my phone off at
seven i don't want to leave let's back
up
no need to apologize you've already
stated right
they should apologize to you for
violating your boundary
true so hey i asked you not to call
after seven
why did you come here so i would tell
you that the door isn't the place for
the y
conversation because they're going to be
all gussied up like
just don't answer the door don't answer
the door yeah
yeah and then since your phone's off and
you've got your white noise machine on
you're not going to hear it anyway
and it's this i can hear it in you you
have this compulsion to make sure the
people around you
are okay that's not your job
your job is to make sure you're well and
taken care of
because you deserve it
everybody does exactly but all of us
who are helpers like to make sure
everybody else is okay because that's
where we get our value and esteem from
everyone else is okay and then we get
super annoyed when they don't have the
same respect of
our lives and our boundaries and then it
it was a big shock to me to realize
oh i'm in charge of that i'm in charge
of my boundaries of my wellness of my
taking care of me
and that's super annoying because that's
hard real
real hard and real real annoying um
so what do you do you make firm
boundaries and then you hold them
and then know that the people in your
world are going to try to lean up
against them are they real they're going
to hold are they real are they real
they're real they're going to hold and
number two if they violate them
you have a direct non-apologetic i asked
you not to come over and you rang my
doorbell
till 10 o'clock last night please don't
ever do that again
i was exhausted i'm going to school
taking a break
oh my gosh we just wanted to play i'm so
sorry but it's cool i hear you
um please if i tell you i'm going to be
out i'm going to be out okay oh my gosh
i'm so sorry i'm
i'm sorry come on dude we're just going
to go to the show i don't want to go
show
um i need some sleep so thank you so
much we'll go to the show next time i'll
let you know when i'm ready
to go back to the show and it's with a
period of 10 of it
um and then either they're going to bang
their head up against your boundary a
few times and realize they don't like
you anymore which is super cool
problem solved or they're going to honor
your boundaries and you're just going to
be that weird friend that goes to bed
early i'm that guy in my friend circle
and they're going to continue to reach
out or they're going to send you a text
and be like hey if you want to we're all
going to fill in the blank and then you
get to decide
and i love those because then i get to
decide and i go sometimes i don't go
sometimes
and i don't lie i don't make up like i'm
just not going to go
thank you or i'll be there see you there
you get to decide those boundaries
and practice having those hard direct
conversations because they're the rest
of your life anna and i'm so glad that
someone with your heart
is out there changing lives especially
being a doctor who's interested in
lifestyle change you just made my whole
heart
swell bigger and bigger than i thought
it could um thank you so much for the
call
um quick left turn here but not really
not really um we're both
uh gonna pay some bills here on the show
and i'm excited about this
and just so you know we get lots of
opportunities to have sponsors on the
show to
talk through certain things like hey
would you guys want to sponsor this and
that
and we pass on a lot we pass on a lot
this is a big deal because i'm getting
this call over and over and over in
direct message
and email and email and email deloney
i'm looking everywhere in my community
for someone who
i can go see as a therapist you keep
telling us to go see a counselor you
keep
telling us to go see a therapist and the
wait list is
a hundred years they're only no one's
taking insurance they're only taking
cash and it's
800 a session that's an exaggeration um
or i went to the one good counselor in
my community because i live in a small
town in rural kansas or north nebraska
or wherever
and there's nobody nobody nobody and i
went to one counselor and they're
terrible
right and they just want to talk about
themselves and whatever
and this is an exciting move i was super
skeptical when this kicked off in covid
when every therapist on earth put their
practice online because we couldn't go
see people
i'll never forget when my dissertation
chair a
guy that i have high respect for who is
my mentor through the counseling program
i won't tell you how old he is but he's
older than me and
he said hey like he's not the most
technic tech savvy guy
and he said hey i've moved my practice
online
and i have to just say it um this
changes everything
i'm a better counselor i'm a better
therapist i am able to show up
my clients who don't have a ton of money
are able to
not waste an hour driving across town
and then sitting in session for an hour
and then wasting another hour across
to go back to work because they're
working hourly and it's expensive and
it's
they can just go out in their car they
can go in their house they can go
in a safe space with their ipad with
their cell phone and we can do
counseling direct and so we partnered
with better help
and i'm so excited about this
partnership for you the listener
this is live not just like high five bro
count count uh coaching right this is
customized online therapy it offers
video
phone even if you don't want phone or
um on a video live chat
you can go back and forth with your
therapist if you get
connected with a therapist and you don't
connect with that therapist
you can tell them there's a process for
getting a new one there's a process for
getting another one right
you can join millions of people who are
in therapy they're seeing what it's all
about it's virtual it's
online it's on the phone it's texting
it's
direct it's on your terms here right
it's way more affordable than
traditional in-person therapy
and you can start communicating with a
therapist in in less than two days
right so it's not like i'm having a
crisis now
i just found out that he cheated on me
today i found out that she's leaving me
today
and they go great cool we'll be able to
see you in six to nine months right
no less than two days you're having a
conversation right
here's the deal dr john delaney show
listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
go to betterhelp.com
deloney d-e-l-o-n-y that's
better help b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash deloney 10
off your first month listen just try it
just try it if you've been sitting at
home and you're nervous
especially you tough dudes and tough
women who are like i don't need to do it
let's try it
just try connect betterhelp.com
go see somebody you are worth it your
relationship's worth it your kids are
worth it
everybody in your ecosystem is worth it
do it all right let's take one more call
let's go to dylan
in los angeles california what's up
dylan how are we doing
hey dr d how are you i'm good brother
how are you oh it's just another day
it's just another day well listen this
is important
the astros are going to beat the dodgers
this year so there's that all right so
what's up man how can i help
i don't know about damn angel's family
they super did man they did good
good call for those of you don't know
the astros played the angels last night
and the angels
beat them and it was embarrassing it was
a good comeback win good for them all
right brothers how can i help dylan
man you clowned me on that i am 23 years
old
um and i've been divorced for about a
year and a half
my ages 19 through 22 were pretty bad
and
that included divorce however i've been
with my current girlfriend for about 18
months
um i have been getting some comments
here and there
when are you guys gonna get married what
are you gonna propose blah blah blah
and i thought about it for a couple
weeks hey dylan
talk directly into the phone man
can you hear me now ah way better
perfect okay all right
um i've been getting some comments about
getting married when are you going to
propose
um and i thought about it for a couple
weeks
and i realized i am absolutely terrified
of getting married again
because of uh my last marriage which was
completely self-inflicted
i i've accepted that and dealt with that
but i was wondering how would i get over
the fear um of getting married again the
fear that
that that might end up really badly
again yeah
man i appreciate your question dude um
people all over planet earth are going
through this right now um
it's been a rocky season for
relationships and people trying to
grow something new out of the ash man so
i appreciate your heart on this
um who's making these comments
oh just just some family members and
friends no
they're kind of joking but it just got
me thinking seriously about it
why do you care what they think if
you're not ready right now you're not
ready
what why are you giving audience to
those those
critical voices i guess i take a lot of
i think a lot of what people say i know
i shouldn't and i try not to but i guess
i take
based off of my past marriage and
and how it ended my military career and
it was just really bad based
on that i guess i take a lot of heart to
what people think because
screwed up so badly over the last couple
of years that i just
i take to heart a lot of what people
think and i shouldn't it's a bad
it's not a good thing to do what
happened in your previous one man
uh well i mean i was in the army i was
stationed out there at fort campbell
actually
and uh uh got back from deployment
started drinking a lot
and it just i wasn't the best husband we
had uh we had
my son and then shortly after that it
just fell apart and we separated and
and then divorced six months later okay
so you ran around on her too
uh yeah yeah yeah okay now and here's
what i'm trying to get at the bottom of
um
when you have a situation where a
marriage implodes
right and you may have heard me say this
before and i'll keep saying it over and
over because we don't talk about it
enough as a
as a culture when a marriage implodes
when a relationship that you care about
implodes
when you do something you never thought
you would do which is cheat on somebody
that you love
especially the mother of your kid right
no one ever sets that sets out for that
right
um you lose trust in the relationship
right and you have
the the normal grief and
you know picking up the pieces after a
train wreck of an ended relationship
but beneath that you're you're kind of
hinting around the edges here
you lose trust in you you're like who is
this guy
right i thought this guy i thought i was
better than that
i thought that i was filling the blank
and suddenly you
betrayed yourself right you stumbled and
you thought you were running just fine
and now you're in a new relationship you
like this person you're a year and a
half in it's cool and all great
but you don't trust dylan anymore and
now you're trying to outsource that
trust to other people man and that's
when people find themselves
way over their head making stupid
decisions because you give
audience to idiots right we all do it
man
um but that one buddy who's like seven
beers in it's like bro why don't you get
married and you're like i don't know man
maybe i should right
or some uncle that you wouldn't even if
he called you with a good deal on a car
you'd be like
uh no but he makes a comment about some
right and so
um you start giving you start giving
audience to other voices i really want
to see dylan learn to trust dylan man
so what'd you learn from the last
situation
would you learn about what did you learn
about you
i learned that oh man
i learned to own up a lot i learned to
take accountability of what i do
not try to bury myself deeper lie to try
to make it worse
to to cherish and not take for granted
the people we love
and and the basic things like you know i
have my house my family
not to take things like that for granted
um and just
just not to screw up things that
that you love and you cherish and just
yeah yeah so listen brother
the you just talked about responsibility
you talked about wisdom you talked about
accountability
and you've learned it the hard way but
if you start to wrap your head in a real
way
around those lessons those commitments
at age 23
you're ahead of more than any you're
you're ahead of
most of society look around brother
nobody will take accountability nobody
will make
wise choices nobody will say hey i
screwed this up i have to be better next
time
and you have right so give me
one example of what not taking for
granted what cherishing a relationship
what does that look like how are you
treating this
new person differently than the old
person
um well i mean
she never opens her car door anymore i
always open it for her okay
give me something way more i mean that's
cool that's that's
chivalrous and i i support that i'm an
old texas kid man so i'm high-fiving you
uh give me something deeper than that uh
we actually talk
when we when we get home for the day we
talk about how our day went um
if if one of us has an issue with the
other we sit down
and we discuss what the issue is and
what we're going to go from here
um which i never never did in my last
marriage
you know what that's called brother
that's called vulnerability man
and you know what that is that is the
soil of a relationship that's going to
work
right that you plant in that soil you
can plant any kind of crazy seeds in
that kind of soil
and if you as a 23 year old guy
it's gonna make you a great dad it's
gonna make you a great co-parent with
your ex who's gonna be healing from what
you did for
for years and it's gonna make you a
great future husband
that is what i'm talking about man
that's wisdom that's accountability
that's
learning man good for you dude good for
you
so here's here's the the quick brain
science you got bit in the face last
time
you reached way down to kiss a
rattlesnake and it bit you in the face
and it hurt and it sucked and
you went through a lot of garbage and
you hurt people that you loved
your brain has a vested interest in you
never getting near that rattlesnake
again
ever ever so every time you think about
getting married
of think about a committed relationship
your brain is going to sound every alarm
it's got
okay just know that is your body trying
to take care of you it's trying to love
you the best it knows how
okay you are still learning how to be in
a relationship my guess is your parents
didn't model this for you is that fair
or maybe they did yes okay so you're
flying blind
you're on a mission with with no map
on what a vulnerable southern california
dude looks like
in a committed relationship right
yeah okay so here's the deal i can
give you a hundred percent guarantee
that you never get hurt again
you want it this is a hundred percent
guarantee you will
never get hurt again okay
break up with your girlfriend now and
never be in another relationship again
ever that's a hundred percent guarantee
that you never get hurt
it also is a hundred percent guarantee
that you will never love
never get connected and you will be
miserable the research tells me you'll
die younger
and you'll ultimately hate your life and
so the way to get over the fear
of getting married again getting close
and super connected with somebody
is to do exactly what you're doing you
got to practice
being a better partner every single
day and when you practice it and you
continue to die to yourself
and let her be more important than your
temper tantrums and her be more
important than your anger
and her being more important than
responding to that text from that woman
that you know you shouldn't respond to
because you know where it's going to go
when she's more important than one more
beer and one more beard one more beer
when you die to that self and she
becomes number one
right then brother you are just
planting seeds and you're taking care of
that soil and that sucker is going to
grow and grow and grow and eventually
your body's going to say
oh dude this isn't life-taking this is
life-giving
we're all in on this thing and then at
some point rather you got a risk because
every relationship is risk and so you
got to get back in the ring again
18 months sounds super quick to me how
long have you been divorced
uh almost almost two years
okay officially officially divorced yeah
yeah
um what's the rush man
i mean there's no really there's no rush
i mean i know
as of right now i do want to marry her
but i i just figured i'd face it now
that that i am
i am pretty scared okay so man think of
it as
the first time you did rifle training
and you held that rifle too far from
your shoulder and you pulled the trigger
and it kicked back and almost took your
arm with it right
and the only way to do that better the
next time is to hold that thing real
tight
and that's scarier for your body and you
do it you do it you do it and then
pretty soon
you start getting nervous before you
pull the trigger on that gun right
and so it's both in honor your honor the
fact that your body's terrified of
getting to a relationship again
honor the fact that 18 months is real
quick
right that you're still growing and
you're still learning
and also honor the fact that there is no
grand adventure in life there is no deep
reckless
wild insane love there is no hard
seasonal rises with the with the waves
in the ocean
rad 50 year old marriage that doesn't
come with
wild putting it all out their risk all
in
and i'm going all in on you and i've in
your case you've been all in before
but you only had like a two and a three
and a six and you went all in
because you you weren't playing right
and you lost big
and now you're gonna have to get better
cards and you're gonna practice those
cards and you're gonna go all in
your heart's right brother you're in the
right place dylan keep taking baby steps
keep practicing and here's another magic
thing
be vulnerable with let your current
girlfriend know where your head's at
hey we're we're a year and a half in
i think you're the person for me forever
and i'm terrified because i screwed it
up so bad last time
what are some ways i can continue to get
better do something
real crazy go see a marriage counselor
with her a pre-marriage counselor see if
y'all are on the same page
begin to get some new skills and some
more skills and some more skills man
i've been married for a long long time
i'm still learning new skills
it's all about what the seasons are
going to bring and am i ready for the
weather
when it comes so grateful for your heart
brother you give me hope dylan
so glad you're out there um dude as we
wrap up today's show
let's go with you know what is the
greatest song of all time i love it
i remember when this came out i remember
when this music video came out
i remember thinking this is the greatest
song ever and then i went saw these guys
in concert and they over delivered
three dudes four dudes i don't remember
a little folk band from
the uk man and they released this record
babel in 2012 mumford and sons took over
red rocks in the video
and then man they were here in nashville
and they blew the roof off
never thought a guy with an acoustic
guitar and a stand-up bass and a
banjo and a piano could
blow smoke out of here like it was like
a pantera show dude except
it wasn't the song that took my soul
away took my breath away
my favorite songs of all time i will
wait and it goes like this
well i came home like a stone and i fell
heavy into your arms
these days of dust which we've known
will blow away with this new sun
but i'll kneel down wait for now and
i'll kneel down and know my ground
and i will wait for you so break my step
and relent you forgave and i won't
forget
know what we've seen in him with less
now in some way shake the excess because
i will wait
for you oh my gosh it's so good i'll
wait for you this has been the dr john
dolone show
you